now into its second month the war in
ukraine has failed to give russia the
quick victory it wanted and there are
signs of growing discontent among the
political and security elite back in
moscow
a small band of investigative
journalists has managed to pierce the
veil of secrecy around those officials
among them andre soldata founder and
editor of the agentura website which
tracks russia's intelligence services
he's my guest this week from london
how worried are russia's spies about the
progress of the war people inside are
not really happy with the way the war is
going
and they blame just one guy vladimir
putin for that so who is most likely to
turn against putin and why how long can
he blame others for the setbacks to the
invasion he ordered
is anyone waiting in the wings to take
over if he stumbles
and what are the chances of that can
putin in the long term survive this do
you think
i don't think so
all that and more on conflict zone
[Music]
andre soldatov welcome to conflict zone
thank you for having me
for a long time you and some of your
colleagues have maintained extraordinary
contact with whistleblowers in the
russian security services you implied
recently that failures by russia's army
are causing cracks in russia's
leadership how serious in your view are
those cracks
well that is true correct uh vladimir
putin started with war
by attacking his own people uh and we
see him attacking his foreign
intelligence agency
then he placed on the house arrest two
fsb generals domestic agency but with a
foreign intelligence branch in charge of
the situation in ukraine then it was
returned for the national guard and the
deputy head of the national guard uh was
forced to retire and he was just 45
years old uh so yeah it doesn't look
really good and it sounds really really
different from the previous wars
vladimir putin had and that caused a lot
of confusion inside of the security
services and people inside are not
really happy with the way the war is
going
and they blame just one guy vladimir
putin for that
doesn't he risk turning some of them
into powerful enemies against him after
all it's a pretty ruthless system isn't
it
yes it is but uh
the thing is that um while russian
security agencies and the army
they do not have a tradition uh to
conspire to be honest uh the last time
the russian military tried to
uh to have some sort of coup d'etat was
probably in the 19th century with uh
with
their revolt of decembrist in 1825 and
it didn't go well for them the russian
security services always
controlled the army but it was always
this branch of the military council
intelligence one of the biggest
department of the fsb and they had their
own people
everywhere in every military department
and every military unit so for the
military it's not actually an option
it's also not an option for the security
services because vladimir putin just for
his own security has two uh security
agencies and they're just there to
protect him personally
if you were putin though whose loyalty
do you think you could now count on
unconditionally
i think his uh two personal security
services he has uh the service of the
protection of the president these people
are the closest to him and also his he
has this uh the federal protection
service again these people are well
tasked with providing protection for him
and for higher level officials and
usually these people are very loyal to
him
won't there be insiders in this system
people in top positions who are looking
at the poor performance of the army
looking at this
huge economic backlash from the west
that's about to hit them and saying
we can't survive this it's all gone too
far
you talk to some of russia's spies how
worried are they about the progress of
the war and and the reaction to it in
the west something they don't seem to
have factored in
well yes they are worried but not
because of the reaction of the west or
the one ukraine they're mostly worried
about their positions they see that
putin has been attacking their own
people
for quite some time and to be honest it
started before the war we've been living
in this climate of selective repressions
for probably seven years now and that is
why
uh we have governors and ministers in
jail and also we have fsb people in jail
so people inside they are mostly worried
about their careers uh but of course we
understand now that probably the war is
not going really well
and uh they are
mostly they're thinking about themselves
we do not only we don't only uh have a
tradition to
well of really good conspiracies but
also it's a problem of the lack of
political opposition
well it's very different from what we
had like 20 years ago
20 years ago in russia we still had some
political parties political groups and
if you have say
several generals who are unhappy with
the president at least they had some
political force to go and to ask them
for political support we do not have
this thing now the political opposition
is either in uh
in in jail or in exile
last week one of your fellow journalist
vladimir cechkin who's published a
number of letters from an apparent
whistleblower in the fsb he went so far
as to say that
with every week the war goes on the risk
of a coup against putin is growing you
wouldn't agree with that would you
uh well first of all vladimir he's not
my colleague he's not a journalist he is
a human rights activist
uh and he's a very good human rights
activist he has his own sources but my
contacts inside of the security services
they are not
um
i don't hear from them that they are
ready uh for some sort of action i don't
think they are
there yet
when you say ready
ready in in what way psychologically
ready or ready in terms of
organizational uh movements what
what is that readiness it's it's it's
really difficult for them uh
psychologically
and organizationally psychologically
because
now we have in the russian security
services
people who grew up and made their
careers under one president
and probably under one director of the
fsb
because the guy who is now is in charge
he has been around since 2007.
that means that you have a generation of
of officers who had no experience
with other people i mean with other
leaders with political struggles they
grew up thinking that these presidents
would be forever and that
i would say
narrate their thinking and their horizon
they when you talk to them they usually
talk about their department maybe about
the unit but never about the service and
never about the country
they do not have these big ideas about
the future and mostly concerned about
themselves so psychologically it would
be really difficult for them
organizationally as i said just to build
an underground
organization inside would be really huge
challenge because we have this big
problem of mistrust inside of the
security services so you have middle
level officers distrusting the generals
and generals distrusting the
subordinates
how worried are these people inside the
security services about losing their
privileges and their money and their
their perks because putin has helped to
create a giant kleptocracy in russia
hasn't he
institutionalized corruption in the
police and security services has been
endemic for years hasn't it
yes that is true but starting in 2016
we
have been living in a slightly different
reality
putin stripped the fsb
and other security services of the right
to travel abroad so they already lost
some of their privileges
uh they also they do not have this
officially a right to have properties
abroad
uh so they were under some sort of
uh not repression but some sort of
pressure from the president for quite
some time
so they know but still he has to buy
their loyalty doesn't he with something
yeah yes absolutely yeah they have
enjoying good salaries and all that but
it means that they are not feeling
themselves independent
they are the instrument that is that was
made very clear by putin so you can see
them in every criminal case against the
political opposition or the russian
elites but they are not acting
independently
whatever happens with putin there's no
sign of any liberal faction waiting in
the wings to take over is there none
whatsoever no no absolutely
it doesn't exist and uh to be honest
even the hope that says russian
oligarchs now might be
well
rebelled just because they've put under
the sanctions
well it's not a really
option here these people because they
lost their contracts with their where
some years ago and they were given help
by the government by military contracts
now many of them became part of the
russian military industrial complex and
that makes them even more dependent on
the kremlin and putin
looking at the repression that's been
going on now for some time and obviously
has been stepped up during the war we
have what fifteen thousand people so far
arrested on the streets beatings
widespread intimidation long prison
sentences are you hearing any qualms at
all from the intelligence services that
this is going too far that soviet-style
repression is perhaps no longer
sustainable in 2022
not unfortunately i don't hear that uh
on the contrary people inside the
security services they're quite
convinced that that they are while the
last bastion against the cows they have
this big idea that all the bad things in
russia happened before because of the
revolutions
and they have this big fear that
something like
1917 might one day
uh repeat itself in russia and they have
this
this uh obsession with the revolution
the problem with the revolution is that
in their opinion the revolution was
started by a small bunch of
immigrants not by big political party
that is why they convinced that we need
to suppress
all kinds of political activities no
matter how big it is
so they're fully behind the crackdown
the new crackdown on alexey navalny the
opposition politician for instance and
the extra nine years that he's been
given in jail are there likely to be
more show trials like his on the way all
i expect more short trials but not
against the political opposition because
it's already
non-existent in the country but you can
expect some big
uh criminal investigations against the
russian elites because putin these days
is mostly concerned with uh
with the loyalty of
of the russian bureaucracy and so you
can expect some more governors or more
ministers sent to jail and that is why
the security services are so concerned
because when they see that they are now
under attack
let's talk for a moment about putin's
rhetoric he's spoken of traitors and
scum in society and the need for
self-purification
is he trying to divert blame from
himself and on to those who haven't
supported his war
well he
tries to uh to rely on this
feeling shared by many in the country
that russia is the best fortress
and has been always under some sort of
attack from the west
and uh the biggest
help for the west in this case are
provided by liberals in the country so
actually what is putin's doing right now
is encouraging people to leave the
country remember his famous line that
the russian people will split
uh these traitors out of a mouth just
like a
flea i think that was his expression so
actually he's encouraging people to
leave and we see that
already more than 70 000 i.t specialists
left the country not to mention
uh intelligentsia
journalists and activists there's
pushing out of people who who don't
support the war how does that messaging
go down with the public at large the
majority are still backing the war
aren't they
unfortunately yes and they think that
uh actually it may be good for the
country some sort of cleansing of the
country um because these liberals they
enjoyed they uh well good
way of life and all of that and now it's
time to
protect our country so we have this deep
feeling of of a besieged fortress and
putin knows how to play with it what
about when the public finds out the
scale of the casualties which haven't
yet been revealed to them um
just as they found out when the soviets
were in afghanistan
soldiers mothers have shown themselves
in the past to be a pretty formidable
voice in russian society haven't they
first of all uh this kind of activities
of uh of the organization you mentioned
with
mother soldiers
is
suppressed by their forages so it's not
actually safe for the mothers to to call
this organization and to ask for help
the other problem is that putin actually
he
understood something about the war in
chechnya that for instance it's better
not
to
have soldiers
drafted and big cities sent to the war
that is why you see all these people now
are taking prisoners in ukraine and they
are mostly from siberia from distant
regions and some from russia like
mordovia
and you're saying people won't care
about them
well if you have some people killed and
there and you have their relatives in a
small town in uh in mordovia so of
course
well that would be a problem only for
this small community and not for uh
cities like moscow or saint petersburg
but they were sensitive enough about the
casualties that when kamsa molskaya
pravda the newspaper um printed some
figures briefly on march the 22nd and
then erased them figures which suggested
the army had lost nearly 10 thousand men
with more than sixteen thousand injured
um
they were very worried about that
weren't they so they're doing their best
to cover up the the casualties aren't
they
uh the latest figure is uh provided last
week was
1351 people
killed uh but again of course it's very
far from reality
uh yes you're absolutely right we got
really nervous but uh to my surprise it
didn't trigger any reaction in the
russian society so you have these
mothers you have a relatives they're
quite worried but that's all about it
and to be honest the most astonishing
part of that
is these relatives and mothers they are
mostly worried about the
suns but they are not worried about what
their sons doing in ukraine so there is
this astonishing lack of sympathy for
the ukrainians which to me is very
shocking because every single family
while not single okay every second
family in russia has some relatives in
ukraine
what went wrong with the progress of the
war with the organization of the war
last week igor girkin former colonel in
the fsb counter intelligence said the
war in ukraine was based on a
catastrophically incorrect assessment of
ukraine's forces the enemy was
underestimated in every aspect if that's
true why was the intelligence so poor
uh well because it was not only about
bad intelligence it was also about the
consumer of his intelligence everybody
knows including people inside of the fsb
that putin always has had
strong opinions about ukraine and about
the
functionality or dysfunctionality of the
ukrainian state
and uh we know that he's writing
articles he has his strong opinions so
you say he wasn't going to listen to any
country intelligence is that what you're
saying
absolutely and uh it's not about
it's not about that the russian
intelligence trying to tell him that
look you would be greeted with greater
than flowers it's about a very cynical
approach and assumption that the
ukrainian state and ukrainian people
would just
give up the state would collapse
immediately
and we just need to well to impose our
will and that's it
what happened to the huge investments
russia is supposed to have made in its
armed forces in recent years
we now hear from western intelligence
their claims that the numbers huge
numbers of russian missiles simply don't
work don't fly straight don't explode on
impact what happened was the money all
siphoned off in corrupt deals by by
people connected to the military
well i think
that yes uh the performance of the
russian army is uh not really impressive
but i would blame not only the army but
also political leadership this war was
very different from all the previous
putin's wars in many respects including
the way
uh it's actually led i mean the chain of
command even now is still unclear
in all the previous uh putin's wars you
have this thing it's called the joint
group of forces and usually you have a
commander and you know his name his name
was public i mean you always knew the
name of a general who was ultimately in
charge of a situation on the battlefield
well we've seen seven generals killed on
the battlefield haven't we that's pretty
unusual isn't it to have generals
actually there
absolutely and i think the problem is
that we do not have this chain of
command right now so we do not know
who's in charge and that is why
you have all these problems with
communications we have coordination and
that is why the generals they think that
we need to go to the front line to see
by themselves and they get killed so
it's not really good in terms of how the
whole thing is organized but political
element uh i think still plays a huge
role in that for instance we do not
understand militarily speaking why
uh we have the national guard troops
sent into ukraine these people are
trained to deal with protesters on the
streets
not to be engaged and in tongue battles
and now well then actually for a month
we see columns of these people sent into
ukraine get ambushed uh
killed and burned and nevertheless the
russian government's still doing this mr
saldata what what should we read into
the strange appearance of the defense
minister sergey shoigu after a long
absence from public view was slurring in
his words in a way we haven't heard
before and the rumors reported by the
ukrainians have been that he's had heart
problems is he damaged goods now in
putin's eyes
well i heard from my sources that uh
putin was quite unhappy with uh sergey
shoigo
but what we need to remember that sergey
shoigu is extremely smart and he's very
shrewd political operator he's been
around for 30 years much longer than
putting himself
and he knows how to play with putin so
he could have
some problems with his heart but also he
could play for a time
the problem putin is facing now
is that there is no real replacement for
sergey shoigu we used to have a
collection of popular generals
who became popular because of the second
chechen ones that were in georgia and
syria
what shougo
did he got rid of them
most of them
so if you need to find a good
replacement for shogu right now it would
be a huge challenge and maybe shogu just
wanted to
uh to make sure that putin understands
that
reports in the last few days have said
russia is going to concentrate its
military efforts on the donbass region
uh one should say there's uh so far no
sign is other operations are ending but
is this moscow trying to recalibrate its
war aims to something it can achieve
after having failed to achieve
its initial
aims andre cortonov who heads the
russian international affairs council
says the country's leadership can't lose
no matter what they will need to end
this whole story with some kind of
victory
what if they can't
well uh yes it looks like they're trying
to to provide some explanations uh to
the public and we saw that last week
with uh the russian military going
public uh and talking to some programmer
and media trying to explain what went
wrong or maybe trying to say that
everything is uh still according to the
plan
and now they say yes it was all uh about
don't bust not about kiev uh and we are
not gonna storm all these cities it's
all about an encircling these cities and
then about some cleansing uh so they're
changing rhetoric obviously uh this
suggests panic and disorganization
doesn't it confusion
well not a panic but confusion that's
for clear but to be honest i also i do
not quite understand how putin can get
out of this without claiming some sort
of victory he needs that he needs to
provide some victory to the russians and
to the world because it's all about his
stinging
and
but to be honest i don't quite see what
it might be because even if say he has
some sort of agreement with zelensky the
sanctions are still there the economy is
ruined
and for what
people are talking about a korean style
partition is that a possibility that he
might accept that
uh yes but again it would not be a real
win for uh for russia because he raised
the stakes he said that we need to
cleanse ukraine of the nazis and all
that we need a new deal with nato he's
not getting that so again i don't quite
understand what's his uh end game here
president biden's words in warsaw at the
weekend supposedly off the cuff to the
effect that putin can't remain in power
how do you think that will have been
understood by the various factions
inside the system back in russia those
who may be thinking that also putin's
time should be coming to an end
well there is one striking difference
from what we see
now from what we saw uh in 2014 that uh
when we saw the uh standardization of
crimea
back then
the russian bureaucracy the russian army
and the russian securities all on the
same page
they all supported putin they believed
that it was the right thing to do
everybody got excited and unfortunately
a large part of population also believed
that it was the right thing to do
now there is um a big shift so people
might still believe that something
should be done with ukraine but they
think that the way it was done was not a
very good one and they blame one guy
vladimir putin and i think it's quite
significant
very briefly because we're running out
of time can putin in the long term
survive this do you think
i don't think so
andre soldatov good to have you on the
program thanks very much
thank you
[Music]
you